i'm david reading for reviewer richard
wakeling five games in and sniping nazis
still hasn't gotten old whether it's a
well-placed bullet in the back of the
skull a shot right through the iris of
an unaware enemy or a 200-yard peach
that collides with a pair of balls
sniper elite's schlocky long range
action remains gloriously fun it's in
the moment outside of the sniper scope
where the series has previously
struggled to compel but that all changed
when sniper elite 4 arrived with refined
stealth mechanics and massive open-ended
maps in picking up where that game left
off sniper elite 5 doesn't feel quite as
revolutionary in comparison but with
some smart new additions and a more
ambitious emphasis on player agency and
experimentation this is another
thrilling nazi hunting adventure where
sniping is king
once again you're thrust into the mud
caked boots of american marksman karl
fairburne this time deep behind enemy
lines in occupied france sniper elite 5
is set in the weeks and days just before
during and after d-day when allied
forces launched a joint sea-based and
airborne invasion of normandy on june 6
1944. your initial mission is to
covertly disrupt enemy operations in
preparation for the french theatre of
war destroying aa guns disabling comms
blowing up fortified coastal positions
and so on it doesn't take long however
before you unearth yet another dastardly
nazi plot that could turn the tide of
war so it's up to fairburn to put a stop
to their plants and save the world from
catastrophe now you'll do this by
sniping blasting and stabbing your way
across various locales in northern
france from a picturesque chateau in the
middle of the verdant countryside to the
obliterated coastal town of saint
nazaire where the loy river heads inland
these environments are often gorgeous
especially early on with the colorful
scenery providing a stark contrast to
the violent bloodshed happening all
around it aiming your crosshair at a
nazi's head before taking a deep breath
and pulling the trigger still feels
magnificent there's a gratifying rhythm
to lining up your shot adjusting for
distance and wind and then watching your
bullet propel across the map until it
collides in the most grisly way
imaginable sniper elite 5 has mastered
the cinematic bullet camera with each
shot ending in a violent cacophony of
broken bones ruptured organs and
exploding eyeballs all captured in x-ray
vision to reveal the brutal details
close range combat with pistols and smgs
is solid by comparison with enemies
crumpling from your shots in a
satisfying manner and you can now switch
to a first person view and aim down
sights to achieve slightly greater
accuracy fair burn still isn't quite as
nimble or fluid in his movement as say
metal gear solid 5's venom snake so you
will encounter a few awkward moments
where you struggle to get into the right
position to perform a takedown or mantle
over a piece of cover combat does feel
more personal in sniper elite 5 though
thanks to the inclusion of a deep weapon
customization system there are various
workbenches scattered throughout each
mission with each one allowing you to
augment your guns with a wide variety of
different attachments and add-ons you
can choose from numerous scopes muzzle
attachments ammo types foregrips and
more they might not all be strictly
period-appropriate but tinkering with a
weapon until it's tailor-made for your
playstyle is a treat you might opt to
equip one of the many suppressors and
then combine that with subsonic ammo to
shrink your sniper's audible range
letting you take out targets without
having to mask the sound of your shots
with a misfiring generator the trade-off
is that doing so will increase the
amount of bullet drop making long range
shots harder to pull off
but you can also alleviate the side
effects somewhat by equipping other
property enhancing attachments taking
the stealthy approach is encouraged but
there's nothing really stopping you from
charging in guns blazing or adopting a
chaotic mixture of the two disparate
play styles this has been the case in
the series before but sniper elite 5 is
also more willing to give you increased
agency and how you complete a level
recon planes and french resistance
fighters will sometimes provide you with
intel on potential routes or points of
interest within a level the maps
themselves are absolutely huge too
covering vast swaths of land where a
single level might encompass everything
from sandy beaches and dense woodland to
open fields in small villages retrieving
classified nazi intel from the
aforementioned chateau might be your end
goal in that particular mission but
before you can even sniff its walls
there are numerous german patrols and
checkpoints blocking your path farms in
ransacked houses just begging to be
explored auspicious sniping purchase to
uncover and assassination targets to
eliminate fairburne's platforming
prowess has been expanded upon to
increase your options when traversing
these large spaces you can now use vines
to scale walls and utilize zip lines to
quickly abandon a compromised sniper
spot or cover a large amount of ground
in a couple of seconds this enhanced
repertoire allows for more variety in
how each map is designed too the freedom
each map offers is fantastic but there
are unfortunately a few too many moments
where the illusion is shattered by
invisible barricades whether it's a
waist-high wall you can't clamber over
even though it looks the same as the
ones you can or a thin row of bushes
that prove impenetrable the maps aren't
linear in any sense of the word but
these barriers can make you feel like
you're being guided in a particular
direction at times they can also prove
frustrating when you're trying to avoid
an enemy patrol only to discover that
you're trapped on either side of a path
by foliage the ai is fine for the most
part but the nazis you're up against do
have a habit of oscillating between
being deadly and dimwitted at a moment's
notice one of the best aspects of
sniping is that if you can do it
discreetly it is possible to kill an
enemy who's surrounded by others and
send everyone into a mass panic it's
here where they feel most human because
without hearing the shot or being able
to physically see you they have no way
of knowing where you are if they do hear
the shot they're able to triangulate
your position at which point they'll
attempt to snuff you out it's a little
too easy to escape and simply circle
around behind them for some easy kills
but experimenting and devising new
strategies based on the ai's behavior is
a rewarding endeavor that's less true
though when you're spotted by an
impossibly eagle-eyed soldier or your
covers blown with no indication of how
it happened these instances are
infrequent but it's still disappointing
when your plans are upended due to
finicky ai playing through the campaign
with another player in co-op lessens
these shortcomings a tad but sniper
elite 5 also introduces a multiplayer
invasion mode that's similar to those
found in the souls games or death loop
by turning this mode on you'll earn more
xp for everything you do which can then
be spent on various upgrades like more
health or more inventory however you
will be susceptible to invasion from
another player who can enter your game
as an axis sniper this transforms the
game into a tense cat and mouse affair
as you both attempt to take one another
out the invader can make use of the ai
to track down fairburn while the invaded
player has the opportunity to phone a
scout and reveal their hunter's last
known position much like the rest of the
game there is a lot of freedom in how
you handle an invasion you might try to
lure the other player plant traps where
you think they might go or hunker down
in a defensible position and hope you
can snipe them before they snipe you
whichever side of the coin you're on
invasions are a nerve-wracking new
addition that plays into the series
strengths with a focus on stealth and
the thrill of long distance shooting
sniper elite 5 follows in its immediate
predecessor's footprints with another
massive open-ended sandbox for you to
experiment in there's a renewed emphasis
on player agency this time around that
factors into every aspect of its design
from the way each sprawling map is
constructed right down to the addition
of a broad weapon customization system
invisible barriers tend to break the
immersion at times and the ai can be
overly finicky as it veers between
competence and incompetence fairburn
isn't the most graceful protagonist
either but these shortcomings aren't
damaging enough to seriously dampen the
glee that comes from shooting nazis in
the face from 300 yards away when it
comes to long-range combat sniper elite
5 has indeed mastered the craft
you